[موسيقى]
قديما كان الحكواتي مصدر التسليه الوحيد
ومع ثوره التكنولوجيا اختفى من يوميات
الناس وصار من الماضي الى ان حمل زين
العابدين من عكار الى طرابلس جعبه من
حكايه جده ليقصها هنا على الكبار والصغار
[موسيقى]
السيف بعيد ابو سليم ما يهز شمال ولا يمين
لغايه
[موسيقى]
قديما كان يبقى الحكويتي رمز العالم كلها
كانت تتجمع بالقهاوي ويسمعوا لها
الحكاويتي كل يوم يقول لهم
شغلات هيك بتضحكهم وعبر كمان عبر وخاصه
بشهر رمضان
وبترابلس له نكهه مميزه
يقاتل بحماس لكي
رزق الله لكن بس كمان
المصب القهوه الحمل المهلبيه تبع الاسطوره
اللبن والحليب بيجوا قبل الفطور بشوي حكيم
خبرهم بهالمكان قديه كانت تيجي هالعادات
هيدي بتلاقي
هالناسوا نسوا
بذكرهم بهالشغلات تذكرهم قديم كيف كانوا
يتعاونوا كيف كانت فنجان القهوه ومع دقاته
بس نسيتوا عنتر وعبله
ونسيته قيس وليلى
ونسيته هالحكايات القديمه هيدي ربنا شداد
ينقز وعبله نحن بشهر رمضان بدنا نعفي عنه
ونسمحه ومعلقه ثاني مره ما بعيده شو اسمك
انت
نعم فوصل
لكي ينقذ ليلى دائما الانسان
بياخد من اهله وانا اخذ من جدي كثير يعني
لحقت جدي صرت اسرق منه تفاصيله يعني جدي
كان يسمع هالناس حواليه فيقعد يصير يمزح
معه بصير يحكي حكايات ويصير جدي كان ابو
الشروال يعني كل رفقات جدي شراويل كل شي
هيك لباس قديم حبيت فكان الشروال هو يعني
هو الحكايه يعني ما بطلع عنه صرت متعلق
فيه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات